wer weiß schon von morgen sind
jeden tag das sind
wer
heute morgen sind immer und wieder aufs
neue beginnt
hey wir sind heute in weihenstephan bei
der ältesten brauerei der welt bei dem
bier machen
denn ob es glaubt oder nicht man kann
bierbrauen tatsächlich studieren
das schauen wir jetzt mal an neben mir
ein echter professor heute professor dr
herzlich willkommen grüße sie was sind
sie den professor ich bin professor für
die betriebswirtschaftslehre der
brauindustrie buch das heißt unsere
brauch studenten erlernen von mir das
bwl handwerk zum einen haben wir
natürlich die hörsäle klicken sie den
theoretischen teil
sie haben auch ein praxissemester wo sie
dann ein halbes jahr lang sozusagen im
betrieb arbeiten in der industrie und
das wichtigste das kernstück ist unser
technik um das ist sozusagen eine
miniatur bereich
jetzt hier angekommen neben ihr steht
der simon student im fünften semester
hier immer schon sieht bayerisch von der
optik her und erzählt mir jetzt mal wozu
diese gerätschaften hier eigentlich sind
genau das ist unsere versuchsanlage hier
werden keine standard bier gebraut wie
sie im verkauf zu finden sind quasi dass
das festbier genau
dabei ist es wichtig drei inhaltsstoffe
ins spiel zu bekommen und zwar einmal
dass man das wasser und einem den hopfen
der hopfen hier in gepresster form und
hier noch drei verschiedene waldtypen
einmal des weizens und ein geröstetes
walz um farbe ins spiel zu bekommen
erst werden wasser und malz vermengt um
die süße für spiele zu bilden
später beim kochen wird der hopfen dazu
gegeben der bildet die bittere und die
blumige note das ist alles was drin ist
es kommt nach dem deutschen
reinheitsgebot nur noch die hefe dazu
richtig so deswegen ist es deutsche
bürger weltweit bekannt und hier kommt
das bier aus wird ein fast gefüllt wo es
dann eine woche lang geht wo al baschir
und zwei entstehen und dann auch noch
vier wochen reift wir haben hier vorne
noch ein papier ich den mädels
maklerkosten werden wir haben jetzt
unsere biere
man sieht hier schon einer farbe dass
sie eindeutig auf ein dunkles mainz
verwendet worden ist wobei den weißbier
sieht man schön die hefe trübung sagt
netz gar nichts ich muss es probieren
ja spiel auf jeden fall ist was dran am
klischee dass wir während dem studium
die ganze laufen müsst nein natürlich
verköstigt mir den alkohol in maßen
sowie hier genau aber dafür haben wir
ein extra hörsaal dann kann ich dir so
das war's bei uns hier in weihenstephan
du zeigst mir jetzt noch mal den hörsaal
von euch genau
wir sehen uns das nächste mal und nicht
du hier so lange noch die kunst ist
richtig bis bald